[Music]
zach is in youngstown hi
zach how are you i'm not too bad how are
you
better than i deserve how can we help
so basically long story short i got
injured at work at the beginning of this
year
and one thing led to another now i'm
about
seven months behind on my mortgage
payment
and uh looking at foreclosure um kind of
looking at all options and it feels like
bankruptcy is my only way out
and i'll see if there's any other way
i'm sorry are you feeling better yeah
i'm getting much better i had surgery
a couple months ago and i'm just now
starting to slowly get back into work
by paying you workers comp they
are but that has been a up and down
roller coaster from the get-go i went
about
four or five months without any pay
before it all got settled
hmm are you married uh divorced
okay so you're the only person in the
house
correct okay man i'm sorry
yeah what a horrible thing to go through
okay well let's talk through it for a
second what's the house worth
uh well right now um
i was actually in the middle before i
got hurt uh of
doing some remodeling um
what could we sell it for quickly
um 75 and what do you want
85 okay so you've torn it up enough that
it's devalued even below what you owe
yes what kind of mortgage do you have
fha va
or conventional fha okay
all right and your purpose for filing
bankruptcy is what
mean basically uh it's going to be the
foreclosure on the house
i didn't want to go through the
foreclosure and now i also have
a 500 a month child support 500
a month uh car payment
and about 200 in a debt consolidation
that
i had done after the divorce okay
all right child support is not
bankruptable neither is alimony
okay so that's not going away the car
payment's not going away unless the car
goes away so sell the car
let's uh and if the uh so here's the
thing
bankruptcy is a 10 out of 10 on dropping
an atom bomb
on your credit and your future okay
a foreclosure on a home
except for purposes of buying another
home is about a 4 out of 10.
it doesn't really affect you that much
and
fha does not pursue deficits
meaning hud doesn't come after you if
the house doesn't bring enough
so you can stay there until the
foreclosure have a rental lined up and
move out
and in the meantime pile up cash as high
as you can pile it
sell the car get rid of the 500 payment
the child support's not going away
anyway
and if you do all of that bankruptcy is
not going to
do anything for you
there's no i mean you're going to go
through the foreclosure
whether you file bankruptcy or not yeah
because bankruptcy doesn't stop a
foreclosure and there's not a bankruptcy
that wipes out a car payment unless you
hand them the keys to the car
so you don't get to keep the car without
the car payment right and this car
payment's killing you
so the car needs to leave and this house
is
a mess you're gonna you know you sell
the car and you move into a rental
and you start getting an income coming
in again that's your quickest way to
rebuild your life
you don't need to file bankruptcy i
agree with you david
zach how long would it be before you can
get an income coming back in
uh so i'm starting basically uh on a
sliding scale to go back to work i'm at
about half a day now
okay hopefully within two three months i
will be back full time
yeah same company yes and are they gonna
pay you your back
workers comp that's that's the
main question it's still it's been a
fight since the beginning there's some
paperwork on their side that wasn't
filed correctly
it's a federal job so the department of
labor took over and
they haven't uh haven't been the easiest
to work with either well they're not
working much with
coping any excuse to not work with the
covet stuff so
oh my gosh i'm sorry yeah yeah well i
mean we get your income coming back in
and you know here's the thing have they
given you an actual date on the
foreclosure yet
no not yet so i had tried to apply for a
mortgage assistance to lower the payment
temporarily
and that got dragged on up until
about a month ago and they finally said
that they were denying my
uh plan it really might be five more
months before they
actually do the foreclosure yeah and
just
just live there and pile up cash and get
rid of the stinking car
and get you a cash car with no payments
and um
i'm going to put you into ramsey plus
i've been right where you are it's no
fun
yeah ramsey plus i'll teach you how to
handle money and i get you into
financial peace university
and i'm going to pay for it for a year
because i remember how
it feels to be scared and be right where
you are with a foreclosure breathing
down your neck